happy the french are leaving
but it's not soon enough for the malian
military
they've asked the french to withdraw
immediately not in the four to six
months that french president emmanuel
macron says it will take the people on
the streets in bamako agree
[Music]
france must leave mali france is here to
steal the resources of mali france is
here to colonize molly leave the country
without delay they have been here for 10
years and could not solve the problem
in our tradition if there is a broom it
means we don't want any more we don't
want any more the broom means that
that's why we put a stop to france the
french president says the country's
fight against terrorism in the region is
not over
i think all this must be done with
respect because for nine years now
france has been helping mali equip train
and accompany the malian military as
well as the militaries of the region and
our forces will be relocated a few
kilometers from the border in niger the
security threat remains the malian
military says eight of its soldiers were
killed and 14 injured with four still
missing in an attack on friday
they say it was carried out by an
isil-linked group near the burkina faso
border
mali said it killed 57 of the militants
as relations between mali and france
reached a new low questions still remain
around security groups linked to
al-qaeda and isil still operate in the
sahara region spread across 10 countries
the french may be leaving mali but as
recent incidents show militants can
still carry out deadly attacks attacks
the malian military must now face
without french support
assad beg al-jazeera dakar